reinvention means to me kind of like a
rebirth or a change of what's been
happening in the past an idea of like
changing the ways that I've been done
before so I got started when I was
working for the founder of bonobos and
Eden and managing his portfolio of
private investments after Walmart
acquired bonobos I followed and II to
Walmart working on the M&A team there
and then realized very quickly that some
people loved working at Walmart
unfortunately it's not one of those
people so I decided to go and basically
interview at a ton of consumer venture
firms when I was interviewing I learned
that none of these funds well they all
had something called a vice clause which
prohibited them from investing in
cannabis alcohol nicotine stocks tax
online gambling so a lot of people think
that just because something is alcohol
or cannabis or sucks act it means that
it's morally bad but I think that
there's a huge disconnect between what
good is and what good is it and that's
what I decided that there was a huge
white space to create a fund that
basically only invested in those things
I raised my first dollar was somebody
who's a partner at another fund I sent
them a deck just to get feedback I just
went through the deck one on one and
kind of explained each page why I had
this conviction that I had I went
through and broke down all the
categories and they asked me at the end
of they could invest and I broke into
tears because I really couldn't believe
that somebody wanted to give me money
a lot of private equity funds are now
going into venture capital so I see the
pool getting much bigger bigger and
bigger and bigger
[Music]